ينضم الينا من مقر الامم المتحده نائب
المتحدث باسم الامين العام للامم المتحده
فرحان حق سيد فرحان ما الجهد الذي تبذله
الامم المتحده للتهدئه الان
مناسقنا الخاصه على الارض هو على تواصل مع
الاطراف وايضا مع الدول المعنيه يحاول ان
يقومما باستطاعته من اجل ان يستعيد
الهدوء قد ادانا
الوفيات بين المدنيين الذي الذي التي نتجت
من هذه الهجمات ويحض الاطراف دعا اسرائيل
الى ايقاف عملياتها العسكريه والى ضبط
النفس وسنستمر بالعمل مع كل الاطراف من
اجل استعاده الهدوء تقول نعمل مع كل
الاطراف ما هي الاطراف التي تعملون معها
لتحقيق هذه التهدئه ربما في وقت قريب او
هذا ما تطمحون اليه
نحن نتحدث الى الاسرائيليين والى ايضا
الجانب الفلسطيني بضمنه ايضا السلطه
الفلسطينيه من اجل ضمان عدم حصول اي تصعيد
اضافي هل هناك دول تتحدثون معها تشارككم
هذا الجهد
نحن على اطلاع ان هنالك دول بامكانها ان
تقدمها للمساعده في المنطقه تحاول ايضا ان
تحقق استعاده للهدوء ونحن نعمل معهم هل
وصلتكم اي ردود من الجانبين الاسرائيلي
والفلسطيني ما الذي يقوله الطرفان عندما
تتحدثون اليهم
من المبكر القول في هذه المرحله ما نريد
ان نحققه هو ان نرى العنف الذي حصل اليوم
يتوقف بشكل فوري وان لا يكون هنالك اي
هجمات اضافيه هل تعتقد ان هنالك ما يسبق
ذلك يعني كيف عندما تتحدثون اليهم كيف
تقنعون الطرفين بان يتوقفا عن العنف كما
تصفه
اي تصعيد هو مضر للاسرائيليين
والفلسطينيين ليس من مصلحه اي طرف منهما
وسنده
المنطقه الموجود لديهم لكن الاكثر من ذلك
دائما عملنا بطريقه بناءه مع كل الاطراف
هو نامل اننا سنستمر بهذا العمل
وسنرى وهم سيدركون ان التصعيد في هذه
المرحله لا يصب في مصلحه اي طرف كيف
تنظرون الى ان الاختيارات الاسرائيليه
ايضا كان من ضحاياها مدنيون نساء
واطفال ومدنيون من جيران المستهدفين لم
يكن لهم اي علاقه اي دم
ان المنسقنه الخاصه لاند اشاره الى ان
نساء واطفال كانوا بين
المدنيين الذين قتلوه هذا اوضحنا ان هذا
الامر غير مقبول على الاطلاق وقد قمنا
بادانته
شكرا جزيلا لك من مقر الامم المتحده نائب
المتحدث باسم الامين العام للامم المتحده
فرحان حق